this video was made possible by tab for
a cause raise money for charity just by
opening tabs in your browser with a
mullah report out we finally have some
answers about Russian efforts to
interfere with 2016 election and the
administration's efforts to stymie that
investigation but some of our original
questions remain unanswered the report
raises new questions and now we have to
start thinking about next steps
[Music]
hey legal eagles today we're talking
about the known unknowns that remain in
the wake of the redacted Muller report
as we discussed in a prior video Robert
Muller created a legal framework that
would not have allowed him to indict a
sitting president or to levy formal
charges against the president on
fairness grounds the issue from a legal
perspective is we don't know if mr.
Muller is correct about the unindicted
bility of the president this is largely
a constitutional question we have memos
from the office of legal counsel the OLC
that talk about this but the OLC memos
themselves are not consistent on this
point and the OLC itself is an arm of
the executive branch so it would not be
surprising if they took the view that
their boss cannot be indicted while
sitting in the executive office the only
way to know if a sitting president can
in fact be indicted or to have formal
charges levied against them is to test
it at the Supreme Court and Moeller's
framework that he created certainly
doesn't allow for this possibility which
leads us to the second open question
which is what about the statute of
limitations during the pendency of a
president's tenure Muller takes the view
that he cannot indict a sitting
president we don't know if he actually
would have indicted the president but he
takes the position that he is not even
going to get to that question but
because we don't know if Muller is
correct we also don't know what happens
to potential crimes that a president
committed before taking office generally
speaking most crimes have a statute of
limitations it's in society's interest
for most things to be able to lay to
rest certain offenses that happen
so long ago that it would be impractical
to try and get a conviction years or
decades after the fact
so there's a sunsetting provision after
certain offenses have happened it's not
true for all crimes but it certainly
applies to most of the things that you
can imagine a president having done
before or during office with respect to
obstruction of justice section 32 82 of
Title 18 of the u.s. code is the general
statute of limitations that applies when
there isn't a more specific statute of
limitations it states that except as
otherwise expressly provided by law a
prosecution for a non-capital offense
shall be instituted within five years
after the offense was committed so
unless there is a more specific statute
of limitations in the federal system
it's generally a five-year statute so
practically speaking even if a sitting
president committed the crime of
obstruction of justice what happens if
the president is president for more than
five years what if the president wins a
second term and has committed this
particular crime theoretically if a
president committed a crime of
obstruction of justice and then won his
second term then becoming president
could be like a get-out-of-jail-free
card which I don't think anyone would
support and that also raises the
questions about offenses that might have
been committed before taking office
those offenses may not have a 5-year
statute of limitations there could be a
two or four year statute limitations for
fraud related offenses or there could be
a very specific 1-year statute of
limitations as sometimes happens in
statutory law this is an untested part
of the law Robert Muller's position is
perfectly reasonable that you cannot
indict a sitting president at least
criminally speaking and the corollary to
that argument would probably be that
well you can't actually indict the
sitting president with a crime that
means that the statute of limitations
should be tolled for that period of time
but it's entirely possible that if the
question ever got to the Supreme Court
the Supreme Court says no no mr. Muller
was incorrect you can indict a sitting
president and as a result the statute of
limitations is not told and also by the
way you waited too long to bring the
crime and therefore the statute of
limitations has expired in the president
can no longer be charged with this
offense even after leaving the
presidency that's the problem with
having these untested constitutional
questions that only the supreme court
can answer in this context which brings
us to the next open question we don't
know to what degree of certainty mr.
Muller thinks that the President may or
may not have committed the crime of
obstruction of justice and knowing to
what degree of certainty the evidence
rises would probably help the electorate
and members of Congress to know what
they should be doing in terms of next
steps while the Muller report itself is
often silent about how strong Muller
thinks the evidence is attorney general
Barr in his press conference shortly
before the redacted Muller report was
released said that Muller told him in
person that he wouldn't have found a
crime even in the absence of the legal
limitations that were created as a
result of the framework under which
Muller operated on March 5th we
specifically asked him about the OLC
opinion and whether or not he was taking
the position that he would have found a
crime but for the existence of the OLC
opinion and he made it very clear
several times that that was not his
position frankly given the descriptions
of the factual evidence regarding
obstruction it's hard to believe that
Muller actually said he would not have
made an actual determination in fact the
MOL report itself says that it goes to
great pains to avoid the traditional
prosecutorial decisions and in fact the
molar report says that while he did find
evidence of conspiracy to collude with
Russians that evidence did not rise to
the level of a chargeable offense
so if Muller was capable and willing to
find that the evidence did not rise to
the level of a chargeable conspiracy
with respect to volume one of the Moller
report it doesn't make any sense that he
would have in secret felt the same way
about volume to the obstruction offenses
but left it out of the Muller report
itself and only told the attorney
General William bar that frankly does
not sound accurate which leads me to the
next open question about Attorney
General Bar in bars for page summary of
the Mullen report Attorney General bar
states that he along with Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein looked
at the evidence that Robert Muller
created regarding obstruction of justice
and came to a determination that there
was no obstruction we don't know how bar
and Rosenstein came to this
determination and we also don't know if
it was based on bars view of the
evidence and facts or whether it was
specifically based on bars view of the
president's article to power as we
covered in a prior video bar has a
fairly idiosyncratic view that if the
president is exercising his article to
power it cannot possibly give rise to
the crime of obstruction of justice
the exercise of that power is
effectively unchecked by the judiciary
there are some scholars that agree with
that view of power but most people
disagree so it's important to know how
bar and Rosen Stein came to the
conclusion that there was no obstruction
of justice we also don't know what is
behind the redactions of the redacted
Muller report by one count there were
eight hundred and fifty five separate
redactions on the basis of things like
harm to ongoing matters and grand jury
testimony that is protected by rule 6 e
on the one hand this is not the most
redacted document I have ever seen in my
legal career I've seen documents that
are far more blacked out than this and
it's hard to argue that redacting
information on the basis that it's going
to harm an ongoing criminal
investigation is a bad thing to do but
on the other hand given the disparity
between the bar for page summary and the
actual redacted Muller report I'm not
sure that this Justice Department
deserves the benefit of the doubt with
respect to the redactions that were made
so it is an open question as to what is
underneath all of these redactions and
what we will see in the weeks and months
going forward as is tested in the courts
whether this information
be unredacted and released to the public
or to Congress additionally in one of
the appendices to the redacted Muller
report there are 12 referrals that
started with the Muller investigation
that were made to other US Attorneys
offices throughout the country many of
those referrals are completely unknown
it is blacked out what the referral was
what the subject matter was and we have
no idea what is going to come of these
investigations that started with the
Muller report but were farmed out to the
other US Attorneys offices throughout
the country that have subject matter
jurisdiction over the rest of these
criminal investigations now in terms of
some of the questionable decisions that
the Muller team made at least from a
legal perspective we've already talked
about the legal framework that Muller
created that may or may not be
constitutionally mandated but one of the
things that really sticks out as an
attorney is Muller's decision not to
interview the president Muller stated
that he viewed his role in this
investigation as a fact-finder not to
come to a conclusion about whether a
sitting president has committed a crime
or not but to be able to gather the
relevant evidence while it was still
fresh while the witnesses were still
available to be able to compile that so
that other people and other entities
would be able to make those
determinations so given that it is odd
that the Muller team decided not to
interview the president again that might
have been the right decision but it is
an odd one in the context of a fact
gathering mission so instead of
interviewing or deposing the president
the Muller team decided to issue written
questions that the president was able to
respond to in writing having had his
attorneys look over all of his answers I
tweeted out after the Muller report was
issued that depositions are better than
interrogatories and what I mean by that
is in the civil world at least you have
mechanisms in discovery to be able to
interview witnesses or to ask them
written questions written questions are
called interrogatories and and these
interrogatories can be useful but the
problem is that
the opposing side will review it dozens
of times through their attorneys so that
the information that you receive is not
particularly useful getting someone in
front of a camera in front of a
stenographer under oath and asking them
oral questions is almost always a far
better way to understand what they were
thinking why they did certain actions
and to actually get at the truth credit
where credit is due I would say it was a
very smart tactic of president Trump's
attorneys to prevent and delay him from
sitting in front of an oral deposition
and in issuing these written answers
that are very very safe and basically
don't say anything that could
incriminate the president it was good
legal advice we of course knew that the
president was given written questions
but until now we were not able to see
them now we can finally see the
questions and answers that are listed in
Appendix C to the redacted Mullah report
almost all of the president's answers
come in the form of I don't know or I
don't recall which is of course a very
very safe thing to do it is hard to get
locked down in terms of lying under oath
or committing perjury when you're simply
saying that you don't have a specific
recollection of the thing that is asked
of you the amount of I don't knows and I
don't recalls is interesting also for
the fact that the president has claimed
to have one of the greatest memories in
the entire world one of the great
memories of all time but that's the
issue with getting written answers they
aren't written by the answer they are
written by the lawyers and simply signed
onto by the person who was asked the
questions but Mr Muller says that he
found Trump's written answers to be
quote inadequate and says that the
special counsel had the power to
subpoena the president to make him sit
for a deposition but Muller refrained
from doing so because issuing a subpoena
would impose quote substantial delay and
he felt like he already had enough
information those are not unreasonable
concerns but given the circumstances
this would have been a very difficult
decision
only time will tell whether it was the
right one so in the wake of the Muller
report let's talk about next steps
Muller recognizes that impeachment is
the preferred and constitutionally
sanctioned mechanism here he
specifically states that Congress can in
fact police wrongdoing by the executive
whether the allegations of the mole
report rise to the level of impeachment
is a political question that I will
leave to you but Muller and his team
concluded that Congress does in fact
have the authority to police obstruction
of justice stating we concluded that
Congress has the authority to prohibit a
president's corrupt use of his authority
in order to protect the integrity of the
administration of justice I think it's
clear that the reason that this is in
the MOL report is that this is a rebuke
of attorney general bars view that you
can't use the president's inherent
authority as a predicate for obstruction
of justice Muller and his team did not
buy that argument moreover Muller
recognizes that actual criminal
prosecution is an option after the
president leaves office as does the OLC
memo on which the DOJ policy not to
indict the sitting president is based
specifically that quote the President
does not have immunity after he leaves
office this is a further rebuke of bars
view about the constitutional unitary
executive defense that would otherwise
have prevented a sitting president from
facing charges related to actions that
he or she took while in office House
judiciary chair Jerry Nadler has issued
a subpoena for the full Moeller report
and the underlying evidence related to
the investigation it remains to be seen
what could be contained in those
redacted portions and of course we've
talked about the referrals that are out
there are dozens of cases that were
referred out and we don't even know the
first thing about the nature of those
cases there are also rumblings that a
few Democratic members of the House are
pushing for impeachment hearings whether
this is a good political move or whether
impeachment even has a chance of passing
is beyond the scope of this channel
that's a political question that I will
leave to you but here's what we can know
for sure about the next steps number one
the courts will decide whether to
release the unredacted Muller report and
the
lying evidence number two the dozen or
so referrals to the other US Attorneys
offices will likely result in further
indictments of whom it's anyone's guess
but recall that one of those referrals
led to the president's personal
Attorney's Office being searched and
that's a huge deal it's likely that at
least some other people will be indicted
and number three elected representatives
will have to decide whether to move
forward with impeachment impeachment is
a political tool and it will be up to
the politicians to decide whether to use
that measure or not one other potential
next step is perhaps do some good for
this world
if this video leaves you wanting to make
some positive change in the world
I'd recommend tab for a Cause which lets
you raise money for the charity of your
choice just by opening tabs which you
were going to do anyway
tab for a Cause is a Google Chrome
extension that allows you to pick the
charity of your choice and then every
time you open up a new tab instead of it
being blank it displays a couple of
Bad's and the money that you generate is
donated to your charity there is no
charge to you and it actually does some
good for this world tab for a caused
users have raised hundreds of thousands
of dollars for charity it's the easiest
possible way to do some good in this
world so all you have to do is just
click the link in the description and
sign up with tab for a cause and do some
good by doing what you were going to do
anyway by browsing the Internet
do you have other open questions do you
agree with my analysis leave your
objections in the comments and check out
my other real law reviews over here
where I will see you in court